est ce que vous préférez chez vous
en vous
physiquement
mais physiquement elles dans la tête
enfin bah oui mais alors là on rentre
dans le privé pur porc
non non non c'est des choses vraiment
que je peux pas répondre
qu'est ce que vous préférez ans vous
allez bientôt prendre
dior ça peut être la main droite on sait
peu mais ça d'ailleurs rêver les
spectateurs n'ont pas à fait donc c'est
ce que vous détestez chez vous
son album que je déteste chez moi c'est
tout ce qu'on déteste tous c'est-à-dire
l'impuissance de la lâcheté l'incapacité
à être un peu ouvert des êtres
tout ce qui fait noms de ces personnes
elles aussi ces annonces a fait 25 ans
que je suis sur un divan a vus comme des
aot dit allen savall un tout petit peu
mieux mais je n'ai pas jusqu'à livrer
les vrais se traîne jamais mon cash mais
le plus grand moment de votre vie jean
laurent cochet quand il a illustré et
mis en lumière une phrase mystérieuse de
de feydeau est douce et mais vous pensez
pas que c'est quand même con labro vous
a trouvé dans ce dans ce boîte de nuit
angoulême est en train de vie premiers
moments de ma vie c'est aussi les
premiers flirts une femme de 30 ans
incroyable avec une énorme poitrine avec
un shetland incroyable m'a collé contre
1 c'était un risque à bouhrouz
beaujolais s'étaient tenus par ben simon
et pol pacini ils sont très âgés
maintenant et je marchais j'avais quinze
ces gens avaient un jim hyper serré puis
j'avais l'écart ville mon temps avec des
boucles que j'étais un petit nec et je
veux très très long web maintenant
jusqu'à 48 ans donc je suis un peu en
fin de piste à la revue amèrement et non
menama et elle m'a collé contre le mur
et elle m'a embrassée sur la bouche je
crois que c'est le plus beau moment de
ma vie j'ai senti une langue
je savais pas s'il fallait bouger ou
aller plus loin a été immobilisé et ça
c'est un très grand moment après j'ai
mis la main sur les seins j'ai dit c'est
pas possible
et après
lentement de manière inquiète je suis
descendue vers ce continent noir cette
chose si inquiétante sur lequel sig moon
a tellement travaillé parce que tous les
gens qui frime en disant
c'est comment je la prends moi
j'y crois qu'à moitié
j'y croit qu'à moitié
magalas grand vide et la grande idée
sexuelle c'est que les mecs les mecs
sont totalement terrorisés ça sera un
autre sujet des missions les hommes de
fabrice le pire moment le père moment de
ma vie le pire moment de ma vie
cdg devenir un peu solennel c'est l'ailé
les mauvaises les inquiétudes quand on
passe des choses un peu inquiétante que
dans le corps médical quoi faut être
simple m coutu attend des réponses est
entré les pires moments de ta vie et
puis et puis voilà après il n'y a plus
rien ce qui vous fait le plus rire dans
la vie
télé achat
non ça c'est un peu du conformisme
canal+
qu'est ce qui me fait très rire virait
quand il dit jusque leblanc
grand le sol didier didier non c'est pas
du tout je sais qui a rien pour moi dans
le prochain est ce qu'il ya vraiment
m'interroge en fait parce que je suis en
train de métérologie mais moi aussi au
départ avant les compliments j'avais pas
pensé mais l'on pouvait de fait mais
c'est pourquoi pas ce que j'ai l'air
comme ça parce que bon j'ai été
déstabilisé mais je suis
vraiment prêt parce que j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour toi
ils pourraient faire
faire posé plein de choses à rome c'est
gentil tu me donnes un grand rôle qu'en
europe
bah c'est pas le ga tempérament plutôt
anxieux donc à part quand je travaille
je suis plutôt flipper non mais c'est
parce que vous êtes à dépersonnaliser
que vous êtes un grand comédien c'est
parce que vous n'existez pas oui si vous
existiez mais moi je préférais pernaut
le présentateur de 13h et canal je vois
prompteur qu'est ce qu'on a ce re de
midi palavas bon tu vas chez la
crim très jolie lettre quand j'ai fait
une hommage à pernod qui est un moment
important dans mon existence c'est que
pour moi le jour j'ai rencontré le 13
heures le régional
j'ai vu un grand j'ai vu un homme normal
tout va je pense que si on mettait un un
électro de bonheur entre pernaut le
présentateur du 13 heures que j'aime
beaucoup et mon truc si on pouvait nous
coller quelque chose sur la table ou sur
le tout sur les cuisses et qu'on dise
d'autres bonheurs 12 par exemple sur
pernod ça doit aussi les 8 9 12 14 16
moi c'est plutôt un deux au maximum sur
fun 12 13 mai ça dure une heure quarante
cinq par jour tout le reste du temps je
pense que la vie de pernod d'ailleurs
l'avis de pernod pardonnez moi ça vous
intéresse mais perd nous devant un porno
ça nous intéresse dans une chose très
simple c'est que il m'a dit c'est
hallucinant parce que comment se fait-il
que vous savez comment je rentre chez
moi parce que j'avais parlé qu'en le
voyant au trésor je visualisais ça
rentrait chez lui tu vas avec la voiture
jeu face à face à une peugeot way ou une
renault on épie que sa femme était en
train de finir et puis quelle il
arrivait pernaut qui faisait chérie tu
veux que je mette un peu de biche tu
vois ce que je dirai la femme dit oh
merde tu sais très bien je m'en occupe
jamais allé j'y mets à laraque et ça
c'est un enthousiasme est vital au
nouveau spinosi a pas même nietzsche à
il faut quand même ne pas être dépressif
pour entrer après le boulot et dire à sa
femme je fais un peu de buts et la femme
fait un an que je vais me présenter oui
chérie c'était drôlement les médicaments
qui met la bûche et puis après
l'éphémère je vais garder la bannière il
va garder la bagnole il revient ça c'est
un être qui va bien il a pas les spinoza
il a pas l'une et j'envie totalement
pernaut j'en fais pas un cheval de
bataille médiatique
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus